social media is totally different from
the stage
it's a whole different ballgame it's
just it's nothing to play with
i would say um but
if you like if you funny if you feel
like you're funny
you know you can find a niche on the
stage and not just be doing it because
somebody else said oh you got this
amount of following bro you got to do
this
you got to want to do it it got to be
something that you really
want to do man because
there's only one take on that stage you
can't cut
that now you know it's you can't cut it
you can't say okay let's do it again no
they gonna look at you like what
preach preach you're supposed to be a
professional right
right you know but you got to know the
gifts and talents that god has blessed
you with
wants to go into that stage now you know
yeah you know what's the worst you've
bombed how long you've been doing stand
up
six months have you been booed yet i had
people walked out what's the worst bomb
oh man i had people walked out bro i was
like
yo and i was like i felt it but i was
like i'm not going to stop i'm going to
keep
going just muscle through i'm going to
wrangle them in yeah and i was like
oh my god and that's like that's like oh
my god i think because of my approach of
what i said
and that like kind of messed up
everything from the beginning and i was
like oh
they didn't like that do you remember
what you said
i think i was talking about where i was
in a
not so good way and they wasn't feeling
it they wasn't filling it up oh like the
actual room
yeah you're making fun of the room yeah
that's a good way to turn people off
yeah now because they're like even if
it's 12 people and you're making fun of
the 12 people it's like
hey we're here so yeah we're not here to
ruin your night we're here to support
you
and then it was like okay and it was
like oh whatever
bye they started walking out yeah and it
was like though i was like
i learned from it though you know yes
you learn from i mean it's good to go
through those type of situations because
it's like really okay
he's like god testing you do you want to
do this because this is part of this
you know and it's like okay okay okay
i haven't been through it you know i
know how that feel i know how did the
quiet feel and i know
when people not laughing and not
interested i know them feeling so it's
like
that's fine just go find what works you
know just continue to learn from that
because
i feel like a lot of the great stuff
been through situations like that where
everybody yes so i feel like you don't
have a story to tell with that i mean
if it's just that easy for you i mean
like dang like that's the benchmark
question on this
podcast i ask every comic on here like
what's your boo story
or what's your worst bomb everybody has
because i feel like i was very like
i couldn't believe it you're like
depressed after yeah i was like very
depressed bro and i'm just like
oh man this is crazy and i had to keep
reminding myself man you funny i don't
care you funny forget what the people
say
you funny bro like you don't matter it
don't matter you funny you funny don't
let this
you know forget the people it's like i
can't tweet this one out yes
no retweets no laughs yeah you know and
people was giving me advice after the
show like look it's hard man just you
know
it's just cool man you know it's good
it's good
and like i say once you feel it that one
time it's like okay
okay okay so if it happened again it's
like oh okay
i don't have some good shows that i have
some occasion you know i know you know
you learned how to deal with it yeah
it's failure's the best teacher yeah man
it's
you know once you don't felt it at one
time it's like okay i'm good man and
if it come again i know how to deal with
it it'll come again yeah i'm not putting
voodoo on you no no no no i understand
yeah man
so it's like yeah and that wasn't the
only time there wasn't a way it's been
plenty of times i don't i don't want a
room it's like quiet and i haven't got
what
you know i said joe you know him with a
point like bye
okay that didn't work
yeah and then like okay
yeah i don't have though but in but when
somebody had told me before because i
used to be like
hey this joke didn't work here but it
went good here
yeah you know it's like don't take it
away it's just some stuff just you just
gotta figure out what work
and that's like you know knowing the
crowds yes that's a big thing like
before you go up spot see who's in the
room like why you know see what's um
who's in here yeah else are they
laughing at the comments before you what
are they getting laughs
what style do they like and it's it's so
much see
it's so much stand up that you have to
learn
there's an algorithm oh man you got to
learn that stuff
and that's the process of everything
like i'm going through that process
right now
figuring i'm still figuring that
figuring everything out right now so
just like you said with social media
it's got to be something you want to do
because or the work won't be worth it
you got to want to stand up yeah
you see people with that hour special
you didn't see the 20 hours of failure
behind that space exactly
that's straight up oh man because oh my
god
jesus christ goodness
that i was special it looked good but i
know they went through
so much just to get to that point
yeah you're doing all the right things
man so like you
you're building it up it seems like
you're you're giving the proper
attention to everything along the way
most definitely building it
incrementally and that's going to be
that strong foundation yeah
eventually everything will be here on
the same level yeah
you know thanks for watching hot breath
the verse if you want to support the
show
go join our patreon but if you don't
like supporting a comic on the hustle
at least click the watch more videos to
keep us alive in the algorithm
hot breath